What's happening?
You're changed the future
and you change the past.
What did you do!
You're.
You are.
You're. Yeah.
I'm Batman
Barry, what are you doing?
Our kids are going to see this.
Welcome back, everyone. It's Charlie.
They dropped another new flash trailer
with different footage,
so we'll break it all down.
There's a whole bunch of super deep cut
Easter eggs some of you may have spotted.
If you're brand new to the channel, be
sure to subscribe to get all the videos.
There's a whole bunch of big stuff
coming up.
There's even more Super Bowl trailers
that I'm still working on right now.
That's how many there were.
Probably
one of the biggest things in this trailer
is all the different Batman suits.
Some of you probably spotted the Easter
eggs in the different Batman suits.
Michael Keaton.
The point is that when they go to Wayne
Manor, it looks decrepit, rundown.
It seems like he hasn't
actually been Batman for a while.
Like he's been pretty dormant as Batman.
He's got the super long hair.
It just seems like he's let himself
go, basically.
He's meant to be in his sixties,
so it's not quite Batman beyond age.
He is in his eighties
during Batman and beyond,
but he touches the bookcase
and he's touching a picture
of his parents, Thomas and Martha Wayne.
And it opens
the secret entrance to the Batcave
where you see all of his suits.
Now they jump cut,
and so they just go straight to his suit
so you don't actually see him
walk down into his suit vault.
But in the other trailer footage
where you see them
walking around in his Batcave
and you see everything
all over the place, all the technology
looks kind of rundown and rusted.
Like he hasn't
been keeping it up over the years
recently,
but just starting
with all of his suits here.
The one in the center is the one that you
see him actually wearing in the trailer
is just meant to be his most advanced suit
that he has so far.
They didn't say how many years
he's been dormant,
like how many years since he's
been running around as Batman.
The way he looks, it seems like it's
been more than a decade.
For the most part,
they're all meant to be based on his same
design language from the 1989 Batman suit.
That one is actually in the background
on the right here.
The one directly to the left of it
is the one that he wore in Batman Returns,
just slightly more armored.
That was the whole joke of him using
that suit in the movie because Selina Kyle
was able to use her claws to penetrate
his suit on the far left here.
Super deep cut.
This is meant to be a version of his
very first suit, like his Batman year.
One suit and the Batman symbol
is also different from the others.
If he couldn't tell, all the other Batman
suits have the same symbol on it.
Except for this one.
This is meant to be the Adam West
Batman symbol from the 1966 TV series
The Pistols are also meant to be
grappling hooks, not actual guns,
according to the costume designer
for the movie.
He also said he designed the ears
for this cowl
based on the Golden Age
original Batman cowl from the comics.
So it's like Michael Keaton's
version of Robert Pattinson's
Batman year to a very low
fi early prototype
for what would become his 1989
Batman suit in other future suits.
Speaking of which, for those of you
that always wanted to see Batman
in the movies where the blue and gray suit
from the comics,
the one right behind this is the blue
and gray suit from the comics.
Ben Affleck's Batman also wears
his own version of that in present day
earlier in the movie.
It is meant to be an updated version
that's closer to the design language
of his normal batfleck suits,
but it's still very clearly the blue
and gray suit from the comics.
The next one on the back right
is another huge deep
cut for the Batman Returns movie.
It's the underwater
Batman suit that they sold as a toy,
but he never wore in the actual movies.
It was just one of the many, many toys
that they sold as merchandise.
Speaking of which, the last one on the far
right isn't actually a desert suit,
even though you see the goggles
there, it's actually another one based on
a toy they sold from the Batman Returns
movie called the Arctic Armor Batsuit.
And it was just for cold environments
or cold based villains like Mr.
Freeze.
Raise your hand if you spent
all your money on all those Batman toys.
When those movies came out back in the day
to get those wonderful
toys, they do pretty much the same thing
for every Batman movie.
But it was just special. Back in the day,
there were so many toys.
If you watched the behind
the scenes features,
they talk about all the merchandizing
they did for those movies.
They made so much money on the toys
for the first couple of Batman movies.
Part of the reason for them doing such
weird deep cuts, though, is to tell you
what happened to Michael Keaton's Batman
after the events of Batman Returns.
They're saying that he went on
to have more adventures.
He used these bat suits during them,
also more references to his Batman movies.
I mean, there'll be many across
Wayne Manor.
And during the movie, just in general,
look, we have his original Batmobile.
We have the Bat Wing.
They'll be a bunch of other
classic Keaton stuff in the movie, too.
But the pictures on his bookcase
when he's opening
the Batcave secret entrance,
the one he touches,
like I said, is of his parents, Thomas
and Martha Wayne.
But the other two pictures, Zoom
in and hands is still a little blurry.
But I believe these are meant to be Alfred
and Michelle Pfeiffer.
Selina Kyle Catwoman.
I don't think she's in the movie.
I'm not expecting a cameo
or anything like that.
I think she was busy in the Marvel
Universe filming and the WASP Quantumania
is Janet Van Dyne,
and she is amazing in that movie.
Make sure you go see that this weekend.
But I think they want to say that
he eventually got together with Catwoman
and they had a life together
for at least a little while.
I don't know that they had any children
or if they'll be any references to that.
Like Helena Wayne, for instance.
They actually did do a version of Helena
Wayne during the Batgirl TV series
in the early two.
Thousands in those characters
actually had cameos during the DC TV
crisis on Infinite Earths.
Like Ezra miller
also had a cameo during that.
The way they're explained,
the convergence of timelines in the flash,
jumping across timelines.
They could also say that
his cameo happened while he was doing that
or because of what he's
doing during this movie.
But you probably spotted in his childhood
bedroom where he's talking to
the younger version of himself
who's meant to be about ten years younger.
The reason why is because of the Pacific
Rim poster in
I Am Legend posters in the background.
Pacific Rim was released in March 2013.
In the reason why they want to say that
he's traveled ten years into the past here
is because what else happened
during 2013 A pretty big deal
in the history of the DCU.
It was the year that Zod came to Earth
during the Man of Steel movie.
It was when Man of Steel was released
in real life too.
That was meant to be
the beginning of the DCU in.
The whole idea is
that he's come into the past
and he's changed something in his causes.
Convergence of timelines
so that everything goes all crazy.
And that's how he creates
the version of Flashpoint
where he basically erases
his original future.
And there are no Justice League characters
from his original Earth anymore
in the idea is that
Zod shows up like right after that,
right on time, and there is no Justice
League to stop him, no Superman,
no Aquaman, no Wonder Woman, no cyborg,
no Green Lantern, only Batman.
The two versions of The Flash
in Supergirl, there was a behind
the scenes featurette that Warner Brothers
specifically asked me to take down.
A couple weeks ago.
I did a video about enduring that.
The director actually said,
We have a version of the Justice
League in this movie,
but they're not quite as experienced
as the original Justice League.
Talking about the DCU version,
I think he was just referring
to the two Flash's Batman and Supergirl
forming like a proto version
of a Justice League. In the movie.
They did say
there would be a bunch of other surprises
in the marketing, but I'm not expecting
any like super surprise
characters
during this particular part of the movie.
Like no other special justice
League characters.
They're probably references
to them though.
So what I think they're actually doing in
the movie is instead of
just like a traditional multiverse
type of movie like you would expect,
they're actually combining
the concept of the multiverse hyper
time, which is a DC Comics
thing from the Flash Comics
and the traditional flashpoint story
from the comics
where he tries to change the past
in ways that messing up his own future
hyper time is a little bit different
because that gets into the concept
of a bunch of different timelines
with different possibilities,
which is closer to the way
they treat timelines on the Loki series
in the Marvel Universe
During my Loki videos,
there are a bunch of questions about this,
like What's the difference between an
alternate universe, an alternate timeline,
the way the Treaty in the Flash movie is
that he does something in the Speed force
that causes a convergence
of a bunch of different timelines.
So it's kind of like an alternate version
of Earth, but it's really the same Earth.
And he winds up erasing his future.
So it'd be like combining
a bunch of different timelines,
which is how Michael
Keaton winds up on this earth
and put your tinfoil hats on.
Because I think before James
Gunn was hired,
I believe their intention was to use this
convergence of timelines, this big twist
in the movie, to sort of soft reboot
things at the end of the film and say that
Michael Keaton would be the new Batman
on this earth and Supergirl as well,
because there was footage
from the end of the movie
where Barry's able to free his father
from prison.
He wins his court case.
They kind of did a version of that
on the Flash
TV show at the beginning of season two,
where he gets his father out of prison.
But it was meant to happen
at the end of the Flash movie,
and it was a bit of a celebration like
Batman rolls up in his custom Mercedes.
And is Michael Keaton's Batman.
But it's the main Justice League Earth.
Obviously,
that's all changed now because James Gunn
is doing completely different things
over the next ten years.
I've already done
a bunch of videos about that.
In all the announcements he made,
we also have another look at the Dark
Flash, who's meant to be an evil future
version of the younger version of Barry
in the movie.
The trailer footage they've released
so far hasn't really given any clues
as to why that winds up happening.
You did see the main version of the Flash
screaming no angrily
in his childhood bedroom,
and it sounds like he's
screaming at the other version of himself,
the younger version of himself.
Early speculation
is that they just wind up messing things
up even worse
while they're trying to fix things.
And it just leads to this alternate future
where this other Barry winds
up turning evil.
So as then doing Dark Flash in the movie
instead of doing
just a traditional reverse flash.
But this suit is actually meant
to be material
from the Kryptonian ship, from Zod ship.
I know that raises
so many more questions than it answers,
but I'm hoping that the marketing material
just gives away
some more clues about that.
But I think part of the idea
is that this other version,
the Flash, just can't get over
the death of their mother
the way that Main Barry does,
and that just drives him to become evil.
Well,
that becomes his villain origin story.
Instead of
choosing the better path, like the path
of the main version of the Flash,
the official synopsis for the movie
just reads Worlds collide in the Flash
when Barry uses his superpowers
to travel back in time in order
to change the events of the past
to prevent his mother from dying.
But when his attempt to save his mother
inadvertently alters
the future, Barry becomes trapped in a
reality in which general Zod is returned,
threatening annihilation.
And there are no superheroes to turn to.
That is, unless Barry can coax
a very different Batman out of retirement
in rescue,
an imprisoned Kryptonian Supergirl,
albeit not the one that he's looking for,
like he's expecting to find Clark
Kent Superman, but he finds Supergirl
ultimately to save the world that he is
in, in return to the future,
that he knows the correct timeline.
Barry's only hope is to race for his life.
Run, Barry, Run!
But will making the ultimate sacrifice
be enough to reset the universe?
When they say reset the universe,
I think they're talking
about fixing the convergence
of all these different timelines.
As things start to fracture,
like he starts to make things worse
and worse and worse.
As far as I know,
all the stuff with Ben Affleck's
Batman happens earlier in the movie
before the first version of Flashpoint.
I've already talked about him
getting the flash ring.
It looks a little bit different
from the one from the comics,
but it is based on the comics.
And Ben Affleck's Batman is the one
who's supposed to give it to him.
Like, here's an upgraded suit
and a really cool flash
ring with nanotechnology.
If Ray Fisher had actually been in
the movie as Cyborg like he was supposed
to be a couple of years ago,
he probably would have been the one
to actually build the flash ring, though,
using his mother box technology.
A lot of you've also asked about this
younger Barry wearing yellow in reverse
flash references.
Like I said, at some point
during the movie, he fights the evil
Future version of this younger Barry,
but it's more of like a saboteur twist
on the character,
like someone from an alternate
future timeline
where a bunch of different
timelines are converging
just because of the way
The Flash's messing things up.
Using his Speed Force powers.
She's not in the trailer
either, but the Kiersey Clemons, Iris West
from Zack Snyder's Justice League.
The Snyder cut is also in the movie.
I'm assuming earlier in the movie,
if you haven't seen James Gunn has been
hyping this up as one of the greatest
comic book movies that he's ever seen.
So there actually is a solid chance
that some of these characters,
not everybody, but some of them,
the ones that don't have criminal records,
could come back in future movies.
They are making the Supergirl
Woman of Tomorrow movie.
It's going to come out
after the new Superman Legacy movie,
but it sounds like it's actually going
to be a different version of Supergirl.
So if the Sasha KLA Supergirl comes back,
it might be in some multiverse context.
And I believe the way they're explaining
Henry Cavill in the version of Flashpoint
during this is that his pod was destroyed
on his way to Earth,
like he died on his way to Earth.
And that's why
there is no Superman on Earth.
But again,
I believe they're using the twist
where it's a bunch of elements
from different timelines
all being combined together
on this one Earth,
if you can believe it, The plot
in the original Justice
League flashpoint was a little bit
simpler, even though that was meant to be
a huge, huge storyline.
Reverse-Flash is meant to be
the person who killed Barry's mother,
but I don't think that he's meant to be
a big character during this movie.
There might be a couple light
references to him
other than just like the yellow jacket
that the younger Barry winds up wearing.
Maybe if they figure out
who their main flash
is going to be in the future,
like will they recast
and have someone else be Barry Allen
or will
they just bring in the Wally West Flash
or do something else?
Then they'll do Reverse Flash
in that second movie
before the big James Gunn reboot.
Henry Cavill and Gal Gadot film cameos as
Superman and Wonder Woman for the movie.
Like they literally already
filmed the footage,
so it's sitting somewhere on a shelf.
I believe Henry Cavill
Superman was going to appear to him
while he was in the Speed Force,
and it was going to tease
the coming future movie
version of Crisis on Infinite Earths.
But that was their ten year plan
before James Gunn came along.
Like they're meant to be building up
to a movie
version of Crisis on Infinite Earths.
I don't know if they replace
their cameo scenes with other characters
or different twists, or they just outright
remove them from the film.
It just made it shorter.
If they're lucky, maybe they'll release
those as deleted scenes in the future.
But as far as I know,
this is meant to be one of Ben Affleck's
last movies as Batman.
He did film a cameo scene for Aquaman two,
but then again, so did
Michael Keaton's Batman.
And there was a question
as to which Batman
was going to wind up in the movie,
like they film Ben Affleck's cameo
because they were replacing
the Michael Keaton cameo scene.
Maybe they swapped Michael Keaton back in,
or maybe they removed both of them.
But James Gunn did say that Ben Affleck
was talking to them about coming back
as a creative behind the camera,
like they were talking to him
about directing a movie.
So it is always possible that Ben Affleck
winds up directing the Batman
Brave in the Bold movie.
Let me know in the comments, though,
if Ben Affleck directs one of the upcoming
new James Gunn DC movies,
which one do you want it to be?
Everyone click here for that other flash
trailer with a bunch of different footage
and click here for my Ant-Man
and the Wasp Quantumania Movie Review.
Thank you so much for watching.